e
[Musique]
l'endroit des bonjour bravo vous êtes
une photographe plutôt exceptionnel j'ai
eu l'occasion de vous dire en privé
vous avez joué de tout votre art lorsque
vous étiez en bolivie donnez nous
quelques images de la bolivie
par exemple lorsque vous arrivez vous
atterrissez en atterri à el alto qui est
à peu près 500 mètres plus haut que la
passe alors au cirque ont atterri on
sent un peu l'arctique en prime à nos
poumons parce qu'on n'est pas très très
haute altitude
le chauffeur se dépêcher de leurs des
femmes sur la passe pour qu'on peut
profiter de 500 m de moins de pression
sur les poumons
c'était ma première expérience à une
hausse et haute altitude gérer ça va que
je mangeais trop alors oui je sentais
que mes pouvons certes elle quitté un
peu trop fort quand tu arrives à l'heure
du dodo alors je préférais à mazet des
rapports un peu plus copié sur l'heure
du lunch
oui alors tout va passer tout pesé très
lourd sur votre diaphragme autrement ce
qui vous amène à la base
s'il demande découverte s'est mis aussi
de venir en aide aux gens ça vous amène
par ne sais pas quel concours de
circonstances à vous intéresser un
concours de miss beauté région laval
c'est la nouvelle tendance et on en a
profité pour aller là bas pour aider une
organisation qui vient en aide aux
enfants et aux femmes violentées bons
trucs comme ça et pour financer leur
organisme ils ont décidé de faire un peu
de compagnie de sous et de jeux
corporatifs ou en vain le nom de la
compagnie sur de switcher des choses
comme ça et c'est tellement été un
succès que çà çà çà ils ont décidé de
partir une petite boutique de vêtements
et comme c'est leur première boutique et
ce sont des gens qui travaillent dans le
milieu social nous avait pas tellement
l'expérience marketing et là on a su
qu'il y avait un événement
mais cela passe du sla passons les
approcher carrément pour leurs deux
filles on pouvait leur fournir les
vêtements pour que les mannequins puis
s'il est présenté ce titre alors le fait
toute la campagne autour de cet
événement là c'était avec comme
intéressante
vous êtes parti en voyage en disant je
vais à venir en aide à ce groupe de
femmes là il n'y a pas un plan de
stratégie marketing très très développé
au départ
de fil en aiguille vous mener de front
une campagne qui fait la une des
journaux autrement dit mais bascala ce
sens mais qui était très ouvert qui
voulait essayer des choses nouvelles des
choses intéressantes
le match a été gagnant gagnant autant
avec les gens qui organisait l'événement
de mais cela passe sautée pour cette
boutique l'eau qui met ma vo vrai on se
passe à leur troisième boutique tout à
fait il me semble en train de cracher
des concepts 7 à l'événement ils ont un
succès pour les demandes de france yves
alors non c'était très bien
[Musique]
comme vous allez comme ça rendre service
et venir en aide aux gens c'est pas
toujours de façon complètement
désintéressé vous achetez des produits
locaux que vous ramenez dans vos valises
tant que la capacité de vos valises vous
le permet puis c'est aussi une occasion
pour vous de voyager de découvrir
il m'a fait toujours surtout à marquer
il faut prendre le pouls de ski c'est
sur le marché pour com1 atteindre la
culture parce que les à marcher quelles
sont les habitudes et où elle s'en va à
la mer est très croyant il ya plein
d'éléments qui font qu'on peut
développer une stratégie un clan
d'affaires marketing mais un état ouvert
alors si on n'a pas cette ouverture dès
le départ
en europe les résultats escomptés à la
fête
plus loin une scène dans votre aventure
ou en bolivie qui rocambolesque qui est
digne d'un film à la louis de funès et
peut-être meilleur que sont encore vous
êtes premier vous trouvez dans un
véhicule en train de rouler vers
l'arrière sans moteur avait envoyé des
marchés à l'hôtel à la pâte
et ben moi j'avais mais mes valises et
tout parce que c'était pour aller
coucher à el alto pour les autres
suivaient vitaux comme autrefois
coccinelle en a pris une coque pour
aller vers l alto et arrive à la lumière
aux feux de circulation pilote véhicules
décider qui meurt c'est ouf
et lol ben rhodes de vitesse lui est
resté dans la main et là moi j'étais
assis avec les balises un peu coincé
jusqu'à m'a fait un peu trop envie de
sortir du véhicule alors qu'ils ne se
contentent de cambrai 6 roues pour
qu'ils accordent à scène de trottoir
puis on avait ça sortir du véhicule
là on a trouvé le seul moyen de le
remettre en fonction c'était que
il recule pas vraiment d'alxa main alors
moi et l'ontt qui nous accompagnait on
était au milieu du chemin à zéro voiture
à leur faire signe de stars c'est parce
qu'il y en avait une sorte d'hydre qui
l'ont alors on avait vraiment la fosse
et finit par remettre le moteur en
fonction à mm et moyenne pression que je
prenne cette côte là une autre fois ça
c'est sûr et certain il fallait qu'ils
trouvent absolument jemeppe de
contournement parce que you babe ruth
[Musique]
et comme si ça ne suffisait pas vous
retrouver à un moment donné sur une
route dans pleine forêt en pleine
montagne l'appui une des plus
dangereuses au monde
la cliente qui conduisait avait amené
son 4-5-1 avec nous a vécu et pour le
retour les chemins qu'on avait pris à
l'aller était barrée dès lors il a fallu
prendre ce qu'on appelle la boîte de
l'enfant effectivement c'est une route
insu spécial c'est ma copine et sur
cette route là on peut pas rencontrer en
un seul manque une voix et on doit te
l'axé mais à tout bout de champ pour
pouvoir laisser passer la personne ça
vient devant nous et on a eu la
malchance sur nos troupes que on a trois
un homme qui était qui venait de tomber
sur la route alors je suggérer un
maquillage d'aller essayer dans cet
entrelacs mm-69 tomber leur tombe et on
va passer par dessus avec lequel par
carte ont dû alors se retrouver avec
presque une routine de cet art devenu
catholique vient par l'avant quelle
belle aventure des souvenirs pour une
vie et ce n'est pas fini vous allez
poursuivre j'imagine vos aventures dans
le monde à la recherche de deux
personnes avec qui vous pourriez
prodiguer une aide il allait prendre une
retraite un jour où vous allez toujours
essayé de faire un voyage de plus à la
retraite c'est pas pour moi c'est pas là
mon vocabulaire à se retirer de coire se
retirer de la vie c'est pas possible on
peut pas faire ça sans volontaire et ça
moi ça me nourrit ses voyages et je peux
pas me priver de notre surface est
certaine cette attaque les caraïbes
on verra vous n'êtes pas aller en
antarctique ça c'est sûr pas encore très
bien merci beaucoup madame tremblay